foreign
[Music]
guys time to do another tone with a
terror book review
so T Kingfisher uh she is a horror and
fantasy uh writer and actually T
Kingfisher is a pen name
um when she does uh children's books and
things like that uh she goes under
Ursula Vernon
um but I think T Kingfisher is what she
writes like fantasy and horror under I'd
actually read one of her horror novels
before I was called the hollow places
from 2020
um and I enjoyed that quite a bit so uh
we had a friend listener who recommended
one of her newest books to me
so I thought well you know I really
liked her other one so I'm going to give
this one a whirl too so I actually ended
up buying uh the hard copy of this book
so this is it uh and it's called a house
with good bones and this came out in uh
2023. so this book is actually described
as sort of like a Southern Gothic
haunted Housey kind of book um and you
know that's right up my alley so you
know what I mean that's why I bought it
now overall I think I loved this just as
much as the hollow places I did have
some slight issues with the pacing which
I'll get into a little bit later but in
the case of this book I mean I adored
the characters particularly the main
character the protagonist and I really
dug the whole concept of it and this
kind of like slow build up of this just
really weird I don't know just like the
build up of it is so weird and you're
just like what the [__] is going on you
know what I mean and it just kind of
like sucked me in and just really kept
me like obsessively you know turning the
pages and going on with it I thought the
climax seemed a little bit rushed and
got resolved a little bit too easily but
overall this was like really really
entertaining and I had a really really
good time reading it so the main
character and the person whose
perspective we see the entire story
through
is actually an archaeological
entomologist uh named Samantha
Montgomery
and she is a delightful character she's
very skeptical she's very sarcastic
um and she doesn't really have uh either
patience or talent for social
interaction which I related to pretty
hard so yeah she seems like very happily
single she's very passionate about her
work with insects
um and so like as The Story Goes On
because it's kind of from her
perspective like you get her thought
processes and she has like all these
little Sly asides and comments that she
makes on things and I mean they just had
me like busting out laughing in places
um I think if Samantha was a real person
I think I would definitely want to hang
out with her because she's like awkward
and awesome and she's also like funny as
[__] I mean seriously I laugh my ass off
at some of the [__] that she said in
this so at the beginning of the story
Samantha has actually been furloughed
from the archaeological dig that she'd
been working on and that's because like
a Native American burial ground they
accidentally uncovered it and you know
you have to go through all the
legalities and stuff to figure out you
know where where they want the bodies
like returned to and stuff like that
um the situation as a whole doesn't have
anything to do with the main story but
it's just kind of like a reason for her
to be out of work for an extended period
of time
now her supervisor has actually given
her some kind of remote busy work that
needs to get done to kind of keep her
financially afloat until the Dig can
continue obviously
um so Samantha decides because she can
work remotely she's like oh I'm gonna
have all this time off I'm not really
sure how long it's going to be so I'm
gonna go back to my childhood home in
South Carolina to stay with my mom
um I think she was in I want to say she
was New Mexico or Arizona or somewhere
like that like where she lived but she's
going back to South Carolina to like
stay with her mom so her reasons for
doing this are kind of twofold like um
so Samantha and her mom like have always
been close and it's like been a while
since she's visited her but kind of the
main reason is that she has an older
brother named Brad
and Brad has called her and told her
it's like look I'm really kind of
worried about Mom it's like last time I
was there she seemed a little bit off
like not like she was he's not entirely
sure what's going on with her but he
thought she was acting like pretty weird
last time he was there and he wants
Samantha to like stay with her for a
while and see if she can figure out
what's going on so they're kind of
hoping that her behavior isn't maybe
like an indicator of early onset
dementia but that's kind of where their
heads are going so they're like we
really need to you really need to stay
with her for an extended period of time
and see if you can figure out if that's
what it is or if it's not that what
exactly her deal is you know what I mean
so Samantha gets to this house where she
grew up and it's kind of in this kind of
bland middle class very cookie cutter
suburb
um that actually has absolutely nothing
to distinguish it from any other similar
neighborhood it's like totally boring
totally uninteresting all the houses
look the same and they're all you know
just kind of little perfect to middle
class neighborhood you know what I mean
now this house previously belonged to
Samantha's grandmother who is called uh
Grand May and she died 20 years ago now
Samantha Brad and their mom were
actually forced to move in with Grandma
like back in the day I can't remember if
their dad like left or died or something
like that but they you know so their mom
was a single mom and they had to move in
with the grandmother and neither Brad
nor Samantha when they were kids were
real big fans of grand May
um she was very old school Southern
um and had this kind of idea like this
kind of like very strict 50s Leave it to
Beaver kind of Standards about what a
family should be and if you didn't live
up to those standards then she was real
um crotchety about it like and she was
very very strict like I said she wasn't
physically abusive really it seemed like
but she for sure like caused some
emotional trauma in both kids that um
they are still very much dealing with as
adults even though it's been 20 years so
when Samantha gets to the house she
starts to notice what her brother was
talking about pretty much right away
like Mom sort of seems like her normal
self sometimes like you know
occasionally
Samantha also notices that the house has
been redecorated closer to the way it
was when Grand May was still alive which
is kind of disquieting because
Samantha's mom like always had these
sort of like funky like more eclectic
kind of tastes like she'd had like
brightly colored walls and like cool
artwork and everything like that but now
the house like the walls are just these
kind of like boring like off-white kind
of colors everything's just very
you know just very boring and beige and
ugly uh and worst of all the thing
that's most alarming mom has reinstalled
this kind of racist painting of like a
Confederate wedding like over the
fireplace now Grand May loved this
painting uh but mom always hated it so
there it is like they're wondering why
because like after her grandma died like
Mom put like a much cooler like piece of
artwork into like a scientific I think
it was kind of like a um I can't
remember it was almost like an
archaeological kind of thing that was
like really cool but yeah so she's put
this Confederate wedding back up there
so Samantha's like why the [__] did you
put that I thought you hated that
painting
um and Mom just kind of like oh well
Grand May loved it and boy and she kind
of like deflects the question a little
bit right Samantha also notices that Mom
seems kind of like nervous any time that
Samantha brings up Grand may it seems
like before this mom kind of
acknowledged like how shitty her mom was
like the grandmother was but now she
seems to be taking Gray great pains to
defend the old bat like even though
Grand May has been dead for 20 years and
can evidently like no longer hear what
she's saying so it's like why is she oh
it's fine she wasn't that bad and she
never did that and Stefan Smith's like
she absolutely did do that what are you
talking about so this is like really
really weird right so there are a couple
of other things going on too
uh for example Grand May when she was
alive was always known for her gorgeous
Rose Garden like outside the house and
this Rose Garden still looks completely
fabulous and perfect outside of the
house even though mom insists that she
does not touch it she doesn't maintain
it she's like I never had a green thumb
you guys know that it just looks like
that naturally which you know that seems
a little sus Samantha also notes to her
dismay that there are absolutely no
insects in the Rose Garden either now
she's an entomologist so she knows that
this is completely unnatural and she
can't figure out what the [__] is going
on with that there's also the small
matter of vultures constantly sitting
around the property uh and they seem to
be watching the house
so they have this neighbor lady who
lives on the same street her name is
Gail and she had something she's like an
older lady and she had a little bit of a
rivalry like going on with grandma back
in the old days like especially like
about their Gardens and stuff which
seemed to be mostly what it was but she
kind of cryptically tells Samantha that
the vultures are keeping an eye on the
house which again seems a little bit
weird so as the days go on like more
even more bizarre events like start to
ramp up like the house is besieged by a
swarm of ladybugs for example
um there's kind of some minor
Poltergeist type activity like you know
pictures falling off the walls like you
know in mass and things like that
um and also Samantha thinks that she
feels like an unseen something or other
like combing its fingers through her
hair like while she's sleeping
Samantha also notices this very alarming
detail that she never noticed before in
this old framed photograph of her like
from her high school graduation like
they took a picture of her in her cap
and gown like out in the Rose Garden and
it almost looks like there's like a
child's little pale hand like coming out
of the dirt in the Rose Garden like by
her ankle and nobody ever noticed that
before but she notices it this time and
she's like what the [__] so for the
first three quarters of the book or so
like little events like this keep
occurring and this really
goes a long way toward like contributing
to this mystery of like exactly what's
going on now it's pretty clear that it
has something to do with grand may but
for a long time you're not entirely
certain what the deal is it seems more
complex than like a simple haunting and
because you're asking yourself well why
would Grand May suddenly start haunting
the place after being dead for two
decades like nobody's noticed her ghosts
like wandering around prior to now so
why now you know what I mean and I will
say that the explanation for the events
is far weirder than it first appears but
here's kind of where the issues that I
said I had with the pacing like come
into play now I actually I love the idea
of the of the story like the whole
concept of the story is great but I kind
of felt like the build up was so good
that by the time everything just goes
balls to the wall bat [__] at the end it
seemed like it all got sorted out like a
little bit too quickly like the story
seemed a little bit lopsided to me like
it's going along at this kind of like
very steadily ratcheting kind of pace
like laying out like all these little
mysterious details and you're like oh my
God what's that's weird what the [__] is
going on with this like with the hand
and the roses and the bugs and all that
kind of stuff and it's just like and
you're not really sure what's happening
but then like right at the three-quarter
marker they're about like this really
out there thing happens and then after
that I mean it seems like it kind of
comes out of left field a little bit
because it's like so it's such an
escalation from what had happened before
I guess is what I mean
um and then from that point it just like
I said goes balls to the wall and it all
seemed to like happen and get sorted out
just too quickly and like too easily a
little bit like don't get me wrong like
the imagery and the uh is really creepy
and really outstanding the concept is
great but I think I would have liked the
whole climax of it like fleshed out a
little bit more and also like the
mythology behind the concept like the
explanation of it to
um kind of have been built out a little
bit more like I said so I think the the
last quarter of it like the Final Act I
would have liked that to have been a
little bit longer you know what I'm
saying because it just seemed like it
got sorted out too quick but that said
that like don't take that as to too much
of a negative criticism because I
actually really did love this book I had
a great [__] time with it and I would
actually like unreservedly recommend it
to anybody who liked any of t t
kingfisher's other stuff and anybody who
loves a good Southern Gothic because
this isn't a classic southern gothic but
it does have a lot of aspects of that
um you know the idea of it behind it is
like really cool really original like
really really good and the characters
are really I really like the character
particularly the main character but like
some of the other characters are great
too
um they're very compelling and they
actually seem like real people you know
what I mean
um and I'm gonna say too that like some
of the scenes and some of the imagery in
it is like legit unsettling so if
there's that too
um as I said I would have liked more
expansion uh of the third act because it
just seemed like it happened too quick
because the first uh three quarters was
so good like such a slow build up but as
a whole I really really like this a lot
and um you know this is the second book
of hers that I read and I've really
enjoyed both of them so I'll definitely
be reading uh more of her stuff in the
future that's for sure so that will do
it for this tomes of Terror hope you
guys enjoyed it remember to like share
subscribe and all of that good stuff and
I will see you guys again on the next
one bye